[Applause]
that our intro was all about me
convulsing at your wedding but i really
did worry like it just was too much at a
certain point i was so happy for you
that i was like
i'm really here by the way this is not
you're the by the way i love the
cameron diaz that was awesome that you
totally perfected that technology
no i'm really here in the studio this is
real oh my gosh
in new york it's a good point happening
didn't even think of that baby steps
buddy baby steps we're coming back
i i feel a little enveloped by my chair
yeah it's kind of lily tomliny right oh
my gosh
when you go on a universal uh tour which
you've like hosted
yeah um they have the incredible
shrinking woman shopping cart just still
sitting by the side of the road
yeah how about the the guy the actor i
wonder obviously they can't do it now
but the actor that plays
uh psycho anthony anthony perkins if you
go on the universal tour
you go past the psycho house and the
actor comes out with a knife and chases
the tour
the tram in a family-friendly happy way
i clearly got that with a knife he's
great he's fantastic
um okay i i'm so excited for
five more sleeps till christmas oh
please i
i'm freaking out that i'm here i'm
actually on your show this is
the most coolest bizarre thing ever and
i gotta say i watch all the time i'm so
proud of you and who else would start a
show during a pandemic
and uh and knock it out of the park we
you of course you would do this and we
talked before we started i was gonna say
you were
you and nan obviously were the two
people i leaned on the most
and you could have bailed you could have
started later on you could have started
next year and you're like no way
i'm doing it now people need this and i
go i'd love this
i'd love this and you're like i'm coming
to new york i'm moving my family from
the west coast
yeah i'm taking this seriously i'm
showing i go dude you're going for it
and it's
fantastic and look at it it's great and
everyone's so happy and
safe and it's just what you're doing for
so many people in the bff
shout out to the bff yeah i love that
i love the bffs i go yeah i mean just so
you know like
i've spent the last over a decade
watching you well over a decade again
pisces timeline when did you start late
night
it's about yeah 12 years ago something
like that you know the fun thing about
the the show and
it's like you have to try all these
things and you go some things work some
things don't work
uh i don't know if you remember you were
always game on our show
uh to try a new thing and we did a thing
called lick it for 10. do you remember
this
yeah so excited happened again oh can
covet or you can
it didn't even happen when pre-covet
trust me the [ __ ] didn't work
but i was like true we're going to do a
thing the idea of the sketch was that
the bit was that we just bring out a
product and someone licks it and we give
you ten dollars
yeah we thought that was so funny you go
oh that's great we have made t-shirts in
the nbc store
that are on discount they're very
available right now anytime
i would buy one lick it for ten and it
just stay it just sank we tried like
four times but
i love i love those bits and you look
back and you're like oh
my gosh and then some things go like ah
let's do this thing called thank you
notes
and that stays with you for 12 years and
you go and it's like all those
but it's fun watching someone launch
something because you're like
what's this thing what that oh that's
gonna work that's gonna stick and it's
just
i don't know i think it's fresh and it's
cool and you're doing such a great job
i mean i just don't know how you keep
reinventing the wheel and being such a
first
you just did your third round of
winning this incredible pioneering race
of just
really showing what's possible and
because you're such a renaissance man
and a variety person you were able to
carry that
but you were able to carry it from
network to platforms to
viral to social media and then you
did it again for the tonight show and
then we went into the scary home show
and you showed what was possible there
and that was that was
i the home show was nancy that was that
was my wife that she because
no one knew what was happening and it
was march 12th i want to say
the exact date and uh we i went to my
house uh uh upstate and uh
and my wife was like what's what's your
plan what are you gonna do i go
there's no plan we don't know what and
she's like you have to do something this
is when you have to
show up and she was reminding me of that
david letterman
uh quote we love where he said uh um
being courageous is the best you know
after 9 11.
yeah i was talking about you know
everyone that showed up and
you have to be courageous and he goes
even if even if you
uh pretend to be courageous yes it's
just as good almost i mean it's like and
i think of
you know i thought of that and i'm like
oh yeah i'm not the front front line
workers i'm not a nurse i'm not a
teacher
and i'm not a cashier at a store was
being brave to sell you
food and you know so you can feed your
family but i can entertain
and i can do something so i and raise a
lot of money for charity
we did every dude we did this we did
these we started on youtube we just
again
on youtube again and uh with just my
iphone and nancy was the director
yep holding the camera winnie and franny
would make the signs for what charity
you were doing that day
dude winnie and franny they they are not
actor kids at all you cannot
like say say goodnight terry when they
go good morning you know whatever i go
oh
gosh i want to hire kids to pretend that
they're my kids like
these are aren't they cute like they
look nothing like you i go uh but
they're great actors
uh we had one where i was interviewing
uh russell wilson and ciara
and uh and uh um winnie lost her two she
lost three teeth while we were doing
these things and she lost a tooth and
she came he's like
dad dad and his blood all over my mouth
and i'm like
you know for us it's cute because it's
my kid you know but no
the world is gonna go what happened to
your child